A good movie title should be memorable, but
they don't always have to make sense.
On occasion, filmmakers end up with titles
that are wildly—and sometimes hilariously—inaccurate.
Here are some movie titles that lied straight
to your face.
The Lone Ranger
In no iteration of The Lone Ranger is the
heroic cowboy actually lonesome; his sidekick,
Tonto, is always by his side.
As a character, Tonto is almost as famous
as the Lone Ranger—in fact, in the 2013
movie adaptation, the guy who played Tonto,
Johnny Depp, even earned top billing over
the guy playing the Lone Ranger, Armie Hammer.
Fargo
The only scene in this Coen Brothers classic
that's actually set in Fargo, North Dakota,
is the one when Jerry meets with the two hitmen
to set up the kidnapping of his wife.
The rest of the movie takes place in Minnesota,
specifically in Brainerd.
"Brainerd?"
"Yeah, yeah.
Home of Paul Bunyan and Babe the Blue Ox."
Sure, you could argue that calling the movie
"Brainerd" wouldn't be as exciting, and the
meeting in Fargo spirals out into all kinds
of craziness, but it's still the equivalent
of Gotham taking place in Metropolis.
You'd think that two seasons of the awesome
Fargo TV series would correct the location
a bit, right?
Wrong!
"Double whoops."
Most of the series takes place in other towns
throughout Minnesota, North Dakota, and South
Dakota, with Fargo visited only a few times
throughout the show.
"You do know you're in North Dakota, right?
Friday the 13th: The Final Chapter
Yes, the fourth movie in the Friday the 13th
franchise is indeed the final installment
in the saga of drowning victim-turned hockey
mask-wearing mass murderer Jason Voorhees.
"But now, Jason's reign of terror is over."
We all thought Friday the 13th Part IV was
going to be "The Final Chapter" when it came
to Jason, but little did horror fans know
that there'd still be Friday the 13th Part
V: A New Beginning, Friday the 13th Part VI:
Jason Lives, Friday the 13th Part VII: The
New Blood, Friday the 13th Part VIII: Jason
Takes Manhattan, Jason Goes to Hell: The Final
Friday, Jason X—the one where he goes to
outer space, the 2003 crossover Freddy Vs.
Jason, and the 2009 Friday the 13th reboot.
Batman Forever
Not quite forever.
The third big-screen Batman movie obviously
couldn't have an infinite running time, though
this thing certainly seems like it never ends.
"Exactly."
But it did well enough at the box office to
generate a sequel, Batman & Robin.
That one was so poorly received that it prevented
the Batman franchise from going on forever.
"What killed the dinosaurs?
The ice age!"
Another Batman movie wouldn't be made until
almost a decade later, with Christopher Nolan's
franchise reboot Batman Begins.
The Karate Kid
Everything about the 1984 original The Karate
Kid is unassailable, including its title,
although 23-year-old Ralph Macchio stretched
the definition of "kid.”
But the 2010 remake, starring Jaden Smith,
isn't about karate at all.
In this version, Jackie Chan teaches his young
charge kung fu, not karate.
Considering Kung Fu comes from China and Karate
comes from Japan, having a movie where Chinese
action star Jackie Chan teaches Kung Fu to
a boy living in China and calling it "The
Karate Kid" is a downright lie.
Mission: Impossible
All of Tom Cruise’s top secret spy missions
as Ethan Hunt turn out to be possible after
all, even if they are pretty difficult.
Viewers can tell Hunt's missions aren't impossible
thanks to the existence of multiple sequels—if
any of them really were impossible, he and
his whole team would be dead.
"Whoo!
That was not easy, but I did it."
Jurassic Park
Yeah, it takes place at Jurassic Park.
"Welcome to Jurassic Park!"
But it should really be named Cretaceous Park,
because nearly all of the dinosaurs in Jurassic
Park actually date to the Cretaceous period.
"Alan this form of species has been extinct
since the Cretaceous period."
The Jurassic era came before the Cretaceous—by
about 80 million years.
Now if only they could explain that to the
dinosaurs…
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
inaccurate movie titles we missed…